Claims data offers an expansive
view of the patients health
history.
Specifically, claims
data include information
on demographics, medical
history, and medications.
They offer insights
regarding a patient's risk.
And as I will demonstrate,
may reveal indicative signals
and patterns.
We'll use health
insurance claims
filed for about 7,000
members from January, 2000
until November, 2007.
We concentrated on members
with the four main attributes.
At least five claims with
coronary artery disease
diagnosis, at least five
claims with hypertension
diagnostic codes, at least
100 total medical claims,
at least five pharmacy
claims, and data
from at least five years.
These selections yield
patients with a high risk
of heart attack.
And a reasonably rich medical
history with continuous
coverage.
Let us discuss how we've
aggregated this data.
The resulting data sets
includes about 20 million health
insurance entries, including
individual, medical,
and pharmaceutical records.
Diagnosis, procedures,
and drug codes in the data
set comprised tens of
thousands of attributes.
The codes were
aggregated into groups.
218 diagnosis groups,
180 procedure groups,
538 drug groups.
46 diagnosis groups
were considered
by clinicians as possible risk
factors for heart attacks.
Let us discuss how we
view the data over time.
It is important in this study
to view the medical records
chronologically, and to
represent a patient's diagnosis
profile over time.
So we record the cost and number
of medical claims and hospital
visits by a diagnosis.
All the observations we have
span over five years of data.
They were split into 21
periods, each 90 days in length.
We examine nine months
of diagnostic history,
leading up to heart attack
or no heart attack event,
and align the data to make
observations date-independent,
while preserving
the order of events.
We recorded the diagnostic
history in three periods.
Zero to three months
before the event,
three to six months
and six to nine months
before the event.
What was a target variable
we're trying to predict?
The target prediction
variable is the occurrence
of a heart attack.
We define this from a
combination of several claims.
Namely, diagnosis
of a heart attack,
alongside a trip to
the emergency room,
followed by subsequent
hospitalization.
Only considering
heart attack diagnosis
that are associated with the
visits to an emergency room,
and following
hospitalization helps
ensure that the target outcome
is in fact a heart attack
event.
The target variable is binary.
It is denoted by
plus 1 or minus 1
for the occurrence or
non-occurrence of a heart
attack in the targeted
period of 90 days.
How's the data organized?
There were 147 variables.
Variable one is the patient's
identification number,
and variable two is
the patient's gender.
There were variables related
to the diagnoses group
counts nine, six, and three
months before the heart attack
target period.
There were variables related
to the total course nine, six,
and three months before
the heart attack target
period, and the final
variable for 147,
includes the classification of
whether the event was a heart
attack or not.
Cost of medical care is a good
summary of a person's health.
In our database, the total cost
of medical care in the three 90
day periods preceding the heart
attack target event ranged from
$0.00 to $636,000
and approximately 70%
of the overall cost were
generated by only 11%
of the population.
This means that the
highest patients
with high medical expenses
are a very small proportion
of the data, and could
skew our final results.
According to the American
Medical Association, only 10%
of individuals have
projected medical expenses
of approximately
$10,000 or greater
per year, which is more
than four times greater
than the average projected
medical expenses of 2,400
per year.
To lessen the effects of
these high-cost outliers,
we divided the data into
different cost buckets,
based on the findings of the
American Medical Association.
We did not want to
have too many cost bins
because the size
of the data set.
The table in the
slide gives a summary
of the cost bucket partitions.
Patients with expenses over
$10,000 in the nine month
period were allocated
to cost bucket 3.
Patients with less
than 2,000 in expenses
were allocated to cost bucket 1.
And the remaining patients with
costs between 2,000 and 10,000
to cost bucket 2.
Please note that the majority
of patients, 4,400 out of 6,500,
or 67.5% of all patients
fell into the first bucket
of low expenses.